the atlantic daily not everyone needs to
rush for a booster so i'm on i'm on the
atlantic's email list and i get their
daily emails and i saw this on the email
and went and just downloaded the pdf
the united states is reportedly gearing
up to authorize covet 19 boosters for
all adults should you snap one up or
wait here's what to consider
now the author of this carolyn mims nice
um
[Music]
says
if the booster rollout is a tv show as
my colleague rachel guttmann once joked
this evening bought it brought a juicy
if not entirely unexpected plot twist
according to the new york times the fda
and cdc are moving to make fiser
boosters available to all adults not
just those at higher risk
so should you rush out for your extra
dose to help you figure out what's right
in your situation i spoke with three
reporters who have been covering the
vaccine rollout sarah zang katherine j
wu and rachel gutman
previously mentioned to weigh the pros
and cons of running out immediately
versus sitting tight
i'm going to share a few of these things
but that right there that should be
enough right so some
and i did not i did not go and research
any of these four women they are
apparently um journalists who have been
covering this story
that actually tells us nothing about
whether or not they are they know
anything they have done any assessment
of their own whether or not they are
able to um we have these four people
who are maybe journalists
claim to be journalists but we have no
idea whether or not they've been right
about stuff and you know i could have
done that but
um
here we have some of the things they say
this is this is supposed to be what you
the
um you know educated reader of the
atlantic is going to look to to decide
whether or not to get your booster
let's say so of
four people who have apparently no
no particular background here why hurry
this is why hurry versus why wait on
your booster why hurry the shot will
well give you a boost
you're likely already well protected
from severe disease hospitalization and
death thanks to your first course rachel
pointed out but the early science
suggests that extra doses help your body
produce additional antibodies perhaps
lowering your risk of infection
that's a lot to hear say and a lot of
this this this friend of mine says
therefore let's do it
why harry you're around higher risk
people
parents who are trying to protect
unvaccinated kids for example might
consider using a booster as an
additional precaution sarah told me
so two things happening in that one
sarah told me so the person writing this
article is taking no responsibility but
she's only deferring responsibility to
someone else with
equal lack of of actual ability to
assess the evidence
you're around higher risk people parents
who are trying to protect unvaccinated
kids for example
those two sentences put next to each
other as they are makes it sound
like
unvaccinated children are higher risk
people yep unvaccinated children are not
higher risk people
unvaccinated children are very very low
risk people
healthy children don't die from this
disease
healthy children
are at
some risk from the vaccines and it
very much
less risk almost certainly from the
disease not only low risk from the
disease but there is a discussion that
we are not having
which is
the
the vaccines which is not the right term
for them but nonetheless the vaccines
to the extent that they provide
short-term protection
may actually
stave off disease long enough that it is
a danger so for children yeah it is not
entirely unlike the situation that
caused um
parents of our parents generation to put
kids of our generation in contact with
each other when they had chickenpox
which was that it wasn't a serious
threat to our health as children and it
could be a serious threat to our health
later and so there was an argument for
it it was effectively
a crude natural vaccination process
and the idea that
i mean i guess the problem is that
they've just simply rolled the logic in
so that you don't check it the idea that
children need to be protected from this
and therefore parents might do so by
right is
uh upside down yep um
so anyway yes it's uh it's it's just
it's like um
[Music]
uh
it's conversational
argumentation that doesn't subscribe to
any of the uh the normal rules exactly
and because it is is produced here as if
it's conversation it is i think also
being held to a lower standard even by
most readers so
next one you
why hurry you plan to gather over the
holidays on average antibodies peak
three weeks post booster rachel
explained
how
that's amazing three weeks post booster
and then it starts to decline so that's
something right there that they're even
admitting that but earlier the very
first one was um
early science suggests that extra doses
help your body produce additional
antibodies perhaps lowering your risk of
infection
so you just aiming for like the one
moment when you think you're gonna be at
highest risk and you give three weeks
post booster and then like that's your
magic moment and after that you're
you're less safe like none of this is
tracking none of this is is a coherent
message
why wait why wouldn't you go eat your
booster right now even though you're
allowed to
we don't know how to optimize vaccine
timing yet boosters haven't been
available that long so the science on
timing is preliminary
you don't say
extra doses mean extra chances of side
effects getting a booster could increase
your risk of rare side effects katie
explained quote there's a reason we
don't boost unnecessarily end quote but
that she added is not a reason to not
get jabbed if you do need it and how do
you decide if you do need it i wonder
that's left for us to decide
finally keep the bigger picture in mind
boosters aren't a silver bullet katie
reminded me and though this won't be
solved by you
foregoing an extra shot there are lots
of people in the world who haven't even
gotten their first dose yet that's worth
remembering
what
yeah it's a total non-sequitur
whether or not you are going to for your
own health and because you have or have
not seen various things about what these
boosters are what the vaccines that you
got in the first place were
has absolutely nothing to do with
whether or not there are people who you
think should have had access to the
vaccines and don't yet literally nothing
yes
zero there is zero relationship between
those two things this is this is typical
just
garbage
pseudo-causal
liber liberal seeming argumentation that
actually makes no sense it's um
it's effectively like uh
the clean plate club logic like this is
exactly what it is yeah that that's
that's exactly i mean that's exactly
that's exactly what it's alluding to
yeah right
you have to eat your dinner because
there are children and fill in the blank
china
you know starving i don't know what
people say anymore but um that no
actually that's that's that's a
non-sequitur yeah it's a it's a
non-sequitur i mean the whole thing is a
non-sequitur and so but keep the bigger
picture in mind brett well but
you know there's something about the
chatty
pseudo-logical argumentation
right and in some sense
basically what this is modeling
is
if you're going to make this argument
you know what will come back at you and
what might you say right and it's
sort of like it it's just well katie
said right
but you know you can imagine just
substituting yourself as if you're being
clever saying these things but the
question is you're not really being
clever yeah did you hear that the
booster's gonna be available oh my god i
did hear that and i heard that if i take
one now that that might mean that
someone else can't have it so maybe i
should weight these
it's it's nonsense it's not the way that
we should be making these decisions and
unfortunately it is the way that a bunch
of people are making decisions and this
is making that more likely yes and in
like increasing the odds that that
chirpy gossipy
like coffee clutch level of conversation
is the basis for decisions about your
health no
no it's not no it shouldn't be yes it's
going to be you know in fact it weirdly
um harkens back to what we were talking
about earlier in the podcast which is
there are sort of two visions of
uh
what how you will be viewed based on
your position right yeah and if you're
like yeah i'm trying to i'm trying to
get the timing of my my booster
down right the point is well that
assumes that you're going to get one it
assumes that you should get one um and
the alternative of like well wait a
minute what about the adverse event
signal and
do we know what that means yet and
right that thing well you're going to be
shouted down and mocked and treated as
you know you're going to be treated as
the cause of the pandemic if you know
your vaccine skeptical here
um and so the point is you're being
offered a choice do you want to go back
to being chatty about this kind of stuff
or do you want to be the villain right
and can't we just get back to normal
already i feel like it's you guys who
are keeping us from getting back to
normal yeah right yeah exactly and that
is not what the evidence suggests at all
not at all
[Music]